i'm here with nate levine who's the
co-founder of open gov and beautiful
mountain view california and open 5 is a
really cool idea i mean the idea is that
we can get more information about our
governments and governments can get more
information about themselves using your
platform so what we we built as a
platform that as you said takes
government data right now financial data
and and host it in an easily accessible
platform online so government officials
elected officials government staff
citizens can go to one place they can
they can pull up all the financial
history for a government you can pull up
the budget they can look at future
projected spending and revenues and what
they can do is see the big picture
trends can answer basic questions like
how much did we spend on police fire
stuff like that and then you can drill
down into those numbers if you want to
drill in and see how much did my police
department's spend on patrol versus
administration if I want to go into that
patrol division how much are they
spending on police cars how many did
they buy where they buy them from you
can get all that information easily
quickly couple clicks of a button we're
aggregating at all and no in one place
that it's really easy to access and
there's sort of two constituents as i
understand this i mean there's a citizen
who can say oh my god my government is
spending that much on that and then
there's also the the internal like the
government's these are big big
organizations i think you said palo alto
has a budget of 500 million dollars
itself which is just a suburb of san
francisco so there's an internal sort of
auditing almost nothing that they can do
with your soft yeah it's not even just
auditing it's it's it's just it's basic
access to what's going on and you know
as you've said these are big
organizations I mean if these were
corporations these would be usually big
companies as you said Palo Alto so
hundred million we're working with
governments that have multi-billion
dollar budgets Palo Alto is running its
own power utilities they're running
essentially corporations in the
government and and this is spread across
multiple departments thousands of
employees sometimes multiple different
accounting systems it's it's it's a big
operation and it's important to that
operation that the people running it be
able to get instant access to the data
what did we spend what are we spending
it on what are we going to do next year
where's our revenue coming from are we
on budget are we over budget are we
hitting our targets right now
governments spend a lot of time just
trying to answer
questions and that means they have way
less time to actually govern these
decisions about it and so open gov is a
for-profit it does it's venture back
that you said you raised seven million
dollars directly and you're growing
pretty fast you have 46 organizations
that's it yeah yeah 46 organizations on
the platform right now those are mostly
governments we have a lot of cities on
the platform we have counties we have
some state agencies school districts
special districts it's a it's a
recycling disc and this is up in the
minute you're open gov is only one year
two years old now about two years old
but we've really only had our product on
the market for about a year oh yeah so
and this grew out so is this to back the
camera up for a second you started
something as an undergraduate at
Stanford and I understand you still
haven't finished your degree buzz right
everybody watching not very finish your
degree please unless you start open gov
maybe you had something called the
California common sense project correct
yeah so that's a nonprofit organization
I helped start as a freshman at Stanford
University and at California common
sense we were working with members of
the state government in California so
members of the state legislature and we
were focusing actually on budget issues
this was during a major budget crisis
for the state of California we're trying
to help collect data and make reports
and analyses for members of government a
to help them make better decisions and
also be to communicate what they were
doing better with their constituents and
other other policymakers what we found
working on that project was that it was
really hard to get access to the
underlying data we needed to make these
reports governments would be storing
their data in 30 year old accounting
systems legacy systems the vendors out
of business nobody knows how to run it
punch cards using punch cards exactly
it's in stacks of paper we just said
this is this is absurd I mean state of
California 100 billion dollar operation
and it's it's you know using
hundred-year-old technology to manage
what it's doing so going back to open
gov for a second there was a city here
in California called I believe Bell
California that had as you described it
one of the worst corruption scandals
ever and then they decided to use your
software to add transparency right yeah
yeah Oh Bell California really proud to
be working with them there in Southern
California near la and absolutely a
couple years back it turned out that
essentially the government was stealing
money city manager City Council members
were paying themselves
multimillion-dollar paychecks nothing
was being watched they were just
siphoning funds from the government and
that came out you know before and this
is before they because once you had open
gov in would be harder to do that right
that's the idea I mean the idea and and
you know that's not that's not
ultimately our only goal here we you
know we in our observation most
governments are doing a really good job
and well they're mostly honest yeah I
mean maybe a competent but honest well
now and and and really even even we see
a lot you know most things ever met a
very competent and and that's not even
the issue there's don't necessarily have
good tools so so in in vail for example
you know they were stealing his money
and and you know we've gone in since
there's a new administration there and
we've partnered with that administration
to help make all that data available all
their finances available transparent to
help them build trust with their
citizens and kind of move forward as we
have just a minute left so five years
from now how you're going to be all over
the country all over the world are you
still going to be running or helping to
run of them god what's the future hold
that's the goal I mean we we have really
you know long-term goals and long time
lines here I mean we want to spread this
to every government in the world that
needs this service coming we want this
to be a tool that's accessible to
governments small and large we're in 12
states now you know we want to be in 50
stage we want to be in you know as many
countries as we can and and and we think
we can do that we think we can bring
transparency you know better better data
management better data access to
governments all over the world and and
the opportunity at that point are kind
of limitless I mean when we have
everybody on one platform we can start
to help them make smarter decisions help
them compare what they're doing to other
governments we have some very exciting
projects down the road well good luck
with that thank you so much thank you